so at first it was a pole here and a
pole there by a point or two Bernie
Sanders may be sort of getting close to
leading nationally sporadically then it
was more polls by larger margins than
within the margin of error and what we
have today is Bernie Sanders leading in
the last four national polls in a row
and in seven of the last eight national
polls this is an analysis of the polling
not a policy of any particular candidate
we also are going to talk about some
delegate math which I think is very
important to understand now this is in
in only one of these polls does Bernie
Sanders have 30 percent support but I'll
tell you how that can be sort of
deceiving when it comes to the delegate
math in a moment first let's take a look
at the polls the last four polls
released recently our NBC
survey u-s-a that NPR PBS Marist Poll we
discussed earlier this week and
economists YouGov bernie is leading in
all four of those the smallest margin is
for the largest margin is 12 now if you
go back further and you look at the last
eight polls instead of the last four you
will see that bernie is leading in seven
of the last eight polls and bernie is in
that eighth Pole where he's not winning
he's only down three putting him
squarely within the margin of error in
six of the seven polls that Bernie leads
Joe Biden is in second place in one of
those Michael Bloomberg is in second
place now one of the things we've been
discussing is this asymmetrical fight
for the Democratic nomination which
requires 50% plus one delegates that
means that of the 3,980 delegates 50%
plus one would be one thousand nine
ninety one so thirty nine eighty half
plus one is 1991 last week we did the
story where I explained Bernie has to
get 50% plus one why because most likely
if Bernie does not get 50% plus one
the super-delegates who will be allowed
to vote in the second round at the
Democratic National Convention in July
in Milwaukee I believe it is will most
likely select someone else in other
words if Bernie falls just short in the
first round and all of the
super-delegates come in the most likely
scenario is they will all rally around
say for example Pete Budaj
or Michael Bloomberg or whoever we don't
know how that establishment situation is
going to shake out yet but it's not
going to be behind Bernie so Bernie to
win needs 50% plus one delegates now he
needs to start getting a majority of the
delegates in primaries and so far he's
not doing that but if you want to stop
Bernie you need only split the vote
enough divided the rest of the non
Bernie vote enough so that nobody gets
50% plus one and then super-delegates
can end up deciding on that second round
of voting at the convention so it's an
asymmetrical battle that is taking place
but there's something that's less
obvious about the numbers you might look
at the numbers and you might see oh I
don't know Bernie's averaging 27 point 3
in recent polls so if we just run those
numbers there's 339 80 delegates and if
he gets 20 7.3 percent of those
delegates that's a thousand 86 delegates
that's way short that's barely half of
the 1991 that Bernie needs to secure the
nomination and you would be correct in
that analysis but remember that in most
primaries you need 15% to qualify for
any delegates it's what's called the
viability threshold now it's done at the
district level but to simplify our math
today imagine that it's a 15% state
viability threshold let's look at an
example California is a good example
California is worth 416 delegates huge
population very important state where
you can pick up a bunch of delegates
right now Bernie has about twenty six
percent support in California but there
are only three candidates who have at
least 15 percent or more and those are
Bernie Biden and Warren
so if these are the voting results in
California
Bernie's 26% of the vote would get him
almost 39 percent of the delegates
because that's the portion of the viable
candidate support that he has so you can
get 26% of the vote and 39% of the
delegates now you would rightly be
saying hold on a second David that's
still not 50% and Bernie needs 50% plus
one and of course you're correct but
it's far closer than the 26% of the vote
that Bernie has in this hypothetical
example in a state where it's you know
Bernie 25 someone else 17 and that
nobody else gets the 15% Bernie in that
scenario would have 25% of the raw vote
but he would get up.get about 60% of the
delegates so remember if this is not
exact because we're talking about what
is usually district level calculations
and applying them to instant ire states
but the principle is what matters you
might say if Bernie only gets 30 percent
of the vote he couldn't possibly get 50
percent of the delegates you're probably
right but there is a way to make the
numbers work and it's conceivable that
if he can get 35 or 38 percent support
that that would actually get him the 50%
plus one delegates you've got to go
through a number of different scenarios
but case in point
even though bernie is polling twenty to
thirty in most states he's still
according to 538 the most likely of the
candidates to get to that 50% plus one
threshold 538 says that there is a 41%
chance that Bernie gets the fold number
of Delegates that he needs no one
getting the number they need is at 37%
so there's a 78% chance according to 538
that it's either no one or Bernie all of
the other candidates splitting that
remaining 22% of the scenarios and then
of course the next point at which we
will see the dynamics of this race
possibly change will be tonight because
Michael Bloomberg will be debating
Bernie and the other candidates let's
talk about that next one of our sponsors
c-calm they're giving you $5 when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a ten dollar a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
twenty five dollar a month plan tailored
more for small businesses where you can
create 60 card numbers a month and much
more but definitely go ahead and at
least get started with the free plan
you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at privacy
calm slash Pakman